foreign
comes from will in New York will writes
my wife and I earn about 83 000 a year
and have over 238 thousand dollars in
student loans auto loans credit cards
Etc I did a couple of balance transfers
and split a credit card between a few to
get zero percent interest rates on as
much of the debt as possible
I feel we are somewhat on track doing
the debt snowball while still paying the
minimum on some and trying to get the
ones with zero percent interest paid off
before the intro rate expires I just
turned 30 so I'm trying also trying to
build a small emergency fund and feeling
pressured to start a 401 and plan for
retirement
I don't want to be in debt anymore and I
fantasize about paying cash for a house
but fear that will never happen
any advice or guidance you can offer
would be greatly appreciated
um
man it's a tough situation this guy
sounds just like John deloney we've been
there John we're like we're going to
game the system we're going to move this
to the zero percent card and do some
balance transfers no it's it's the when
he says I just fantasized but we're just
just walking around the house when my
wife was asleep at night thinking
ah like I should be able like our life
should be different than this like I
remember that feeling and yes I remember
like trying to come up with every scheme
in the book to figure it out like a way
to cut corners and do different and
whatever yeah
um yeah so let's address one thing
you're doing too much at once man yes we
gotta slow down and focus on one thing
at a time that is the power of the baby
steps which means we're not working on
the emergency fund right now we have our
starter emergency fund of a thousand
then we're doing the dead snowball then
the emergency fund and then we'll start
investing in the 401K
and you're 30. you still have a lot of
life ahead of you a lot of people John
oh I'm 30. it's too late for me John and
the same person at 20 is feeling that
way and the same person to 40s feeling
that way it's not too late but you've
got to take intentional steps and when I
see fantasize about paying cash for a
house and then I look at their situation
that's like me fantasizing about being
the best guitar player in the world but
I don't want to practice guitar ever and
it's just it's part of it like we have
to get out of debt have margin back in
our life to be able to pay cash for a
house so you're right right now it is a
fantasy because you have 238 thousand
dollars of debt and you're sitting here
playing games
I
this is a conversation that's not talked
about enough
um I I think in in me and you we we can
do a better job of talking about it
um
with this type of student loan debt I
didn't have this much but we had six
figures
um we had we got pretty radical we moved
and we I think we we moved into a
residence hall into a dorm right it may
be that living in one of the most
expensive states in the United States is
just not tenable anymore and we're going
to take our jobs and we're moving to
Kansas we're moving to Nebraska we're
moving somewhere where the cost of
living is exponentially less expensive
and that means we're not going to be
able to be in a cool City and that means
we're not going to be able to do some
cool whatevers and this is and that but
this is how much Freedom means to us
um and we're going to pay a little bit
of money to move or we're gonna get new
jobs whatever the thing is we're gonna
get radical we're gonna get radical and
right now 83 000 a year in New York
paying off that much it's going to be
years and years you gotta double that
income yeah six months we got to get
different jobs and I know that you love
your job and I know you feel safe at
your job you got to get different jobs
and we're probably selling the cars
that's right we're selling we got to get
radical about it and we're cutting up
credit cards and we don't care if it's
zero percent or twenty percent we're
going to pay it off smallest to largest
because that's going to make us feel the
progress It's going to motivate us to
actually do this thing yeah and we're
pausing that retirement no matter how
much pressure I don't know who's feeling
pressured I don't know where that
pressure is coming from I I for me it
came it just came from shame it just
came from this picture that this is
investing by now I I'm gonna I'm failing
yeah
just it just spins and Spins and spins
on you and by the way if you choose to
stay in New York we had a teacher who
did that free scream that was like yeah
I was a teacher and the moment I got off
I just went and drove ubereats all night
and then I got up in the morning and did
Uber and then I went and was a teacher
and she did that for a period of time
she paid off a ton enough money right so
if you're gonna stay in New York cool
it's going to cost you a soul tax you're
gonna have to work like crazy but do it
man just do it it's worth it but you got
to go all in and that's been a theme on
the show today is you can't be ish
because you're going to get ish results
and you're going to be be emailing us
and going well I try to do the zero
percent I try to move it over here and
I'm trying to invest because I know
that's good and I want to get that
emergency fund and then you wonder why
you're not making any problems here's a
good example I spent some time with the
Mind pump guys in San Jose awesome guys
I'm really doing for the fitness
industry what Dave is doing he has done
with the financial industry right and
um
you're talking about getting getting in
shape and losing weight and building
muscle and what will is doing here is
like you know what I'm gonna lose some
weight and I'm gonna get in shape and
I'm gonna get stronger and so he turned
the treadmill up as fast as it would go
and he got a barbell and he's got like a
kettlebell and he's running and trying
to lift and throw the Kettlebell at the
same time you're going to get yourself
hurt man this whole thing stop do these
things in the right order right let's
um let's start lifting weights and let's
lose weight and then let's build muscle
over time and then once we get it more
healthy then we can start let's do this
thing in the right order right so same
with will we got a plan for you man just
follow the plan